because i like to make the place really
puddly like
did you get it it's got to be puddly man
umbrellas and that
dms dating apps i don't have time for
that
i don't believe you should kiss a lot of
frogs to find your prints i believe
in grilling them i'm going to be going
on a series of dates to find who
can really wow me this is thrilling
my name is max comedy right now i'm
looking for a nice sweet one
and she's dead i'm out the door no i'm
not worried you know i think she should
be worried to be honest
because i've got a lot of energy today
and i'm very excited
play the cards right that's all i'm
asking for and you don't have to be
too sexy because i don't want your dms
flooding i just want some nice questions
it's a first date yeah it's not
not me in the family yet are we yeah i
need to see her immediately
i'm ready man i'm 100 ready i'm ready
man let's go
[Music]
wait
hello how are you doing you're good yeah
what's your name michael mike
michael max yeah you're good mike's just
mike
michael mike's yeah what's your name
cheyenne brother's cheyenne she is
buff okay you know she's a sweet one
cheyenne nice to meet you look nice
thank you
i've got um red heels on oh is it oh is
it no that's a nice man
so what do you do for a living madam i'm
a presenter and i work in pr
oh is it what about you i just do like
comedy in it what do you do for fun
michael um go out go cinema eat popcorn
go to
fort park uh fly around oh yeah eat in
us all i love eating love eating
would you like to eat anything man i
like lamb do you like them
don't mind lamb what's your favorite
meat like chicken oh yeah chicken's all
right what lamb you see lamb yeah that's
like i love loving it you get it yeah
yeah it's waffles buff it's buffalo it's
bath yeah
it's nice well you don't like the word
buffalo say nice instead that's right
so what's the next question why how it
dance
right i think there's a football match
later there's no watch on your wrist
one day one day i'll just look at my
phone for the time manifesting the rolex
or something
no i don't need that come on why are you
looking at your wrist you stacked that
do you have a good credit score
because you can have money yeah and you
have a bad thing it goes up every month
i look at that i keep an eye on it yeah
it emails me yeah
obviously if my credit score is going
down then i'll feel uncomfortable in it
but i'm getting pluses and greens in
that at the end of the month so
i'm good in it you know what i'm saying
i'm good man
can you do a little tour quick what the
[ __ ] do you think this is
no i just want to know what i'm working
with i just laugh what do we know what
you're working with
like i just want to know like what's
happening because what's happening oh
see
money is a big bundle in that because
man's going to die with this bundle
do you get it that's what kids like if
man died
because if my girl got bunda we can go
to miami
and look at bundes but my wife's called
bunda anyway
did you get it so that's what makes me
feel smooth do you know what i'm saying
like we can look at wonders together
like
but if my girl ain't got a bundle then
i'm gonna be breaking my neck like my
girl's gotta have a bundle man like come
on man this
is essential
have you got any fetishes i like feeding
it
yeah but i don't suck it all night and i
like rubbing it or not
like watching tv or not yeah
yeah if it's painted it's got to be
painted yeah who doesn't paint
their nails especially with open toes
some girls don't yeah some don't people
yeah do you get like
if it's painted nicely white and that
preferably
white yeah white yeah it's got to be
white mainly yeah why why why why is it
this one
is like white toys it's gonna be white
fam the man just likes feet in it humbly
do you suck toes no man don't suck toes
like run
don't i just rub feet in it smoothing
it's like there's a big hand in it
you get me that's what feet is a big
handy don't sting i'll rub that bro
that's all right
where's the lotion then i'll rub it
watch come down with me and that
like get some cream and that i'm bare
tapped i'm tapped i'm tapped i'll
massage your back randomly
like i'll just look at you i'm like
during the massage i like making people
feel
good together like yes that's why they
can't go home
they don't want to go definitely no no
man don't suck toes no no that's weird
that's weird that's the way that's right
no random suctions
men sexually harass women quite a lot or
is it oh that's
oh i'm sorry what's your thoughts on
consent that's gotta be you know it's
gotta be 100
100 yeah so like before you have sex
with a woman do you actually ask her if
you want to have sex with you
no because my full plate can go on for
like
40 45 minutes do you get it you know
like man them their foreplay is quite
short in it they try and go straight to
the point and that
you see you let her finish first before
you she has to finish that's the main
thing do you know what is here i always
think like what people think when
they've left
like left me i want you to you know
yes oh my god that was so fun though oh
my god i didn't know that was going to
happen though
you're doing it for your ego so you're
not doing it to actually please the
woman you're doing it
both because i like to make the place
really puddly
like did you get it it's got to be
puddly man umbrellas and that
sleeping in the corner at the end you
get it that there's no no one's sleeping
the wet patch yeah it's wet like
how do you like that i like my sleep as
well do you get especially after i
finish
like you have to sleep really good you
get it i'm not going to sleep at night
yeah the fingers can do a lot yeah like
a piano in that let me see your fingers
uh why look at our fingers you just said
let me see show me your hands then
i'm not very good for your comfortable
work yeah yeah obviously i was looking
at it because obviously i should have
cut them a bit
i shaved my pits today you know yeah
just for you still did you shave your
teeth
yeah i'm not going to let it grow well
you can you know if you want women do
yeah i don't like that would that bother
you if i just like
decided not to shave yeah really why
what do you know
i'll just pull your pubes out you would
what i'll pull your pubes out
to let you know that this is not on in
it
it's my body my choice pull it like i'm
like yo this is not cool
and what is a hoe in your eyes what's a
hoe someone just sleeps around someone
that's very active very quick
did you not say you sleep around i said
i have many dates but what's wrong with
women being able to do what they want
with them
so why would you why ain't gonna wife
them do you get it if a girl's body
counts higher than 12
she cannot be my girl why do you get it
how many have you slept with i don't
know so you're so you don't know because
it's a lot my body count could be
screaming it could be
500 yeah i'm still going to find a woman
yeah there's gonna be a woman out here
that's gonna take me
yeah there's gonna be a man that's gonna
take a woman that's like with like
that's their business but i'm not gonna
be that good
where is it so firstly i'm not brave
women don't really care about the body
counts these days do they
i'm sick of just the way men have this
power to
you know dictate what is a high and what
isn't you know because energy exchange
is real firstly
and the fact that you've just said that
you've stuck with like 500 of people
and then if i'd step with more than 12
you're saying that's mad
for me right now i'm single and having
fun
whatever i'm single and i want to have
fun don't do that if you tell me at the
end of the night like your body counts
300 i will sleep with you i don't mind
that but you will never be my
wife why but what why do you want to
meet my mom how are you going to meet my
mom
if this double standard that men seem to
have
about women only being able to sleep
with like one man in their life
but they can sleep with a few hundred
like it's not on
what's your body can't tell you oh i
can't tell you 40.
it's less 68. i just said less
20. if you had your body car was 20
oh we have to fly i'll marry you then we
have to fly out of here
because you don't know them you're not
going to go what
you care too much about what other men
think so you won't be with a woman that
could be a really good
i feel like a real man wouldn't feel
threatened by that and he could walk
into a room
with you know a woman that has slept
with men in that room okay
how would you feel if we've gone to a
party together and we're going out yeah
and we've walked in and i've selected
five girls there what happens then
i'd speak i'm not gonna lie i would be
mad but at the same time i get to a
point where
okay you're with me now there's no
judgment there like your past is your
past
can you like get up now please what no
because always i need to teach there's a
meet mark here where i stand up and you
can
i want that one and that one or like
that but maybe there's no other woman
here
did you get it so well i don't know why
she's not twirling for me like maybe
she's just trying to like
you know look after her name and that
but she should have told for man
i've been going through a stage in it
what
like i'll see a woman from far here and
then when she's walking by
and her leg's got bigger legs and that
i'm thinking she's gonna have a big
back do you get it so when we walk past
each other i look back it's not her back
you get it it's just big
legs did you get it and that makes me
sad sometimes what's wrong with that no
because i want a big bat i want to make
sure he's got a big back line
that i feel like if the girl's got a
nice personality nice face and a big
back
his happy day's done with a good river
good um
have a good job as well done that's
that's all i'm asking for i'm not asking
for much
and obviously asking not to cook as well
that's a lot you ask for
is that a lot
what's like the worst thing you've done
in your life the worst thing i've done
yeah i don't know have you ever like
lied or cheated
i've been cheating on have you yeah how
was that for you
i was afflicted that's why i've been
single for eight years
and i'm actually enjoying it like that
because everything i've got is mine and
my family's no one else's
is it important for your like mum to get
on with your girlfriend
yeah 100 and if she doesn't it has to
work do you guys not only me i can't
just like my sister's gone like you
my brother's gonna like you my mom's
gonna like you my dad's gonna like to
get it it's not just about me
because if i marry her now and something
goes wrong then they said did i say
did i not tell you it's okay i know i
don't want that happening i don't want
that to happen to you i'm saying so
um yeah i haven't done it this year
though
oh yeah i have done it this year you
know how many times
once i can't have a like eating out body
count if you get it
what uh eating out body count bro that's
mad imagine your eating out count is
like
fate i thought you said you were big on
4k yeah but the foreplay doesn't have to
be head
no i can't be having no high eating out
count no no no
no that's dead like you can't be eating
and eating and
you get me like come on that's not
trying to get spots on my tongue and
that you get me like he's not trying to
get like gum disease and that
if there's a threesome 100 man's doing
that do you get it why would it be 100
if it's a threesome
because there's a threesome do you get
it like it's not just going to give out
wood in that you get like it's got to be
patterned in that
if she's eating out you have to join in
the night you get it like and then
go oh my god like she's she wasn't
prepared that i was gonna you get it
yeah but what if like the woman's better
going down on your woman
than you are i don't think i'm sure that
can you say
i listen to moans in it you listen out
for moans
like to change do you know what i'm
saying
did you get it
no no no no no no no no why
my wife she can't have my password yeah
not my girlfriend
why do i cause no no no phone postcode
probably when i'm older than that it
might make sense but right now i'm
really enjoying the life right now and
no one's getting my password only me
people always think that one in a phone
pass like passcode is like
to go through your phone and dictate
like it's just something as simple as
just having it because the trust there
doesn't necessarily mean like i want it
to snoop people are different in it
women are different would you snoop on
my phone
if i feel like i need to yeah but i
wouldn't want to i don't want your
password
it will make me sad even if it's not
meant to piss me off it's still going to
piss me off do you get it so i don't
want your password
once i have a wife a girl i'm out like
i'm because what's that why i forgot
that's
it i'm not talking to no one i'll change
my number everything like you get i
don't know very drastic
no no i'm not playing because i know
what i'm like and i know what women do
i already know women i can sleep with
when i'm married how about that
you think these girls carry your
girlfriend is they don't care if i have
a girlfriend they just need the puddles
they remember the puddles in it
would you sleep with a woman that was
married
why is it taking you so long to answer
that really he was doing so well
honestly i really liked the guy until he
mentioned that he would happily sleep
with a woman
that was already taken like things like
that don't sit with me i feel like it's
very immoral
it's not nice and i believe in karmic
energy yeah i would
why that's just morally not right that's
actually wrong
i slept with a girl more than her own
boyfriend before
that's disgusting why would you do that
because i'm trying to show her that i'm
more consistent i don't even have to be
but you don't you don't want to make it
but you want to sleep with her tear up
her relationship she's not terrible you
have no place
she could say i love you too to a man
that's none of my life
but you're making your business
that's fine i will get back to round two
you can say i love you too you
you can walk around i'll pause the music
everything i'll make sure this
relationship works
no i'm so single right now but you're
just you're single doesn't mean you
should
come to me like relationship will tell
them you've got like morally
it's on you to say you have a man or
don't talk to me unless you're single
or if i knew before you go into a
relationship and you're still willing to
see me and it happens it happens and if
your man calls i'll keep my mouth shut
that's the worst thing you've done
actually joe and i asked you what's the
worst thing you've done
that's actually it sleep with someone
that's not available i'm single that's
normal
though and i'm still helping the
relationship i'm not home wrecking it i
didn't call your man i'm not damning
your man saying oh my gosh
like putting the tv on mute so they can
hear that's also they can speak freely
she can lie she can do all the lies
under the sun
and that's why i'm probably still single
to get it because i've seen so many mad
things like that
but you've entertained that that's not
fair on a man that thinks this woman
loves him
you're encouraging her to cheat how can
you not know what you're saying you're
going there
how can you not expect that to be back
at you but what i'm saying is so karma
comes back around if you are happily
sleeping
with someone then when that happens to
you when you're then the partner that
has someone else in here so that's what
i'm saying
karma comes back around and it'll come
back and bite you yes it will
yes it really will
no i will do toast in that for you you
know ams yeah
so you don't need to get up i'll do all
the hot drinks and that the tea and that
do you cook yeah do you eat meat eat
more fish i'm addicted to meatloaf
we better learn to cook then this is
what i mean it's just so crazy that you
expect
a woman no look look so how do you
actually live now
if you don't cook how would you live oh
just visit mum
visit like people got me you know oh
you're one of them
lives by themselves but has no
responsibility that you can still go to
mum's house
wait who does your washing let me let
you shine let me let you shine for a bit
are you that type of guy that will go no
no my clothes are hanged right now
like i wash my clothes like i got dad's
that's not hard like
and this is the thing it's always with
ones that can't cook always have so much
to say about women being in the kitchen
that's not an issue i'm very clean i
would do the cleaning the girl don't
even need to clean i'll clean
because i get that that's a compromise i
get angry when i see mess in that even
when i see you weave like
like just in the bathroom and that like
i don't want to see none of that
on don't know i thought you said the
floor have women around a lot
yeah because women come to visit me that
doesn't necessarily
do you get
what's bree play play with my bum where
you playing rabbit
yeah massage yeah yeah yeah i'll rub it
babe
that's smooth man just watch like come
down with me and i just rub the bomb on
that
yeah yeah i love cuddles though do you
like cuddles in there yeah yeah cuddles
back i can cuddle
cuddling can make me broke really yeah
bro i couldn't stay in bed for like five
days cuddling brother really
yeah like cardinal will make me bankrupt
i'll probably
dance is it yeah i love cuddles like
cuddles is just
dangerous man would you do more than rub
my butt no she's just rubbing the bum
only really yeah i don't do in anything
now
like there's a hole in there yes it is
there's a mouth
we don't want a third hole
personally overlooks
yeah really well my girl's gotta be
buffed all right
so it's looks then no problem personally
excellent she's gonna be passed oh she's
gonna be buff
if the person i don't bang i can't sit
you quite even be my friend
what even friends is like a relationship
to me
when someone's around me they've gotta
play their cards right male
and female personality is very like it
means a lot to me someone
i can have a conversation with someone
and i don't like the conversation i'll
drop a girl back home i've
i've taken a girl out yeah picked him up
on my house
we drove got a couple traffic lights and
we circled back around to her house we
were meant to go out
yeah she said why am i back at my house
because i don't like the conversation
it was just dead it was just like
nothing was happening i don't want this
i don't
yeah you get i don't need to do this my
girl's going to be pretty
that's end of the personality has to
bang as well personally first but she
has to be pretty as well i'm not going
to
go out with some [ __ ] what if what if
i had like the best buyer
like made you laugh everything and i was
ugly
i'll just call you sis all day you could
be a very good friend you can help with
the wedding plan and that
i'll make you cry look i can look at a
girl and i know that can't be my girl
because i know i'll cheat i'll cheat on
her
i can look at one another no i can look
at someone and i know
like i'll make them cry so i don't
bother i don't i don't compliment them i
don't
put myself in a in a position where they
have to keep calling my phone and i
don't
i don't guess people up i don't do that
yep yeah i didn't even need to look at
the card for that
yeah well you'll fight around me yeah oh
that's a come on man
what's wrong with that you're far around
me your first match is like if it stings
where'd it go
you're the one that eats the meat so
yours is definitely going to stink worse
you can't be flying around me like why
you're fighting around me i'm fighting
around you i'm not even going to give
them time of day on that one
let it go no but that's calm if i fought
around you though
and i fought bears you know i've held a
couple here already
no you haven't i have don't have it
don't be disgusting no i might [ __ ]
myself still
well you will fight in front of me
so you wouldn't go in the bathroom one
night if it's first date i'll hold it in
though
yeah get those belly cramps yeah but
once we've had sex and that because
we've had sex i'm fighting now
together and they're really loud they
don't smell though
what would you do if my ex was after you
your ex yeah
i'm out why i don't need to do this i
can do this with someone else i
look i don't need to stay with someone
when this is happening to me
if this is happening to me i don't need
to do this together but why what if i
really wanted to be with you no
because then my mom's gonna find it very
um dangerous my family my friends
they care about me do you get it so if i
told them
my new girl my ex my brother they'll
tell me to lock you off like
everyone cares about my welfare not
yours do you get it do you not care
about mine
no because your ex is looking for me so
i don't need to do it
no go look for go look for a new man
don't look for me i haven't finished
i've got money too i've got
a business i've got like stuff to do i'm
saying so i don't wanna ex looking off
looking for me when i'm doing stuff in
my life so with that so love or money
if you could choose love obviously well
no because
i just said if i loved you and my ex was
after you you just said i've got money
to make
i've got a family i've got i can't like
nothing should happen to me nothing
happens no no no no nothing should
happen to me i said my friends care
about my welfare
what would you do if i didn't sleep with
you for the first six months of our
relationship
i'll cut i'll cut out yeah i'll cover
what do you mean
yeah but what if we had a really good i
have to sleep with you before we get
into relationship anyway
i ain't waiting six months because i
don't need to why
i thought you wanted a wife for mr nice
guy on energies and everything like that
he was saying he wouldn't wait six
months that doesn't even make sense if
their vibe is there then you're willing
to wait
i'm still going to watch a girl that's
going to free up i can still wife a girl
that frees up just the first day
yeah but why couldn't you wait though
like what if i really needed you to wait
no i don't like playing chess
i feel like that's quite insensitive
because there's some women that can't
have sex so easily because of a
traumatic experience
like you that don't want to take the
time to get to know a woman and
everything like that that's really
selfish that's right not a man it's not
selfish to me
i don't know her like that but then
you're not going to get to know her just
because i don't want you
but just because women won't sleep with
you so easily you're not going to spend
time getting to know her
no i will get to know her but if i feel
like this is too chessy or you're
playing games
i don't like i don't like i like
attention just guess what i'm saying
what if it genuinely wasn't it was
genuine
you wouldn't wait six months i'm not
waiting six months i don't need to do
that what am i wearing something cause
it's fine
why is that wrong it's not always about
having sex it's all about waiting and
getting another person
okay if you want me to keep sane in the
brain i need nuts out do you get it
so it depends what you want if you want
like a connection then you'd wait
i don't know maybe when i'm 35 that
might sound normal to me but right now
that does not sound normal i'm look can
you not see where i'm shaking i
just come on this is someone like disney
sex bro look at that i'm switching all
the time
i need to not tonight you okay
i'm busy i've been screaming but my
lungs are in my videos i need to not now
i'm tired the day's over
i need to not you get it simple as that
what would you do if i wanted to start
and only fans
showing your face maybe sometimes bikini
bitter body
look if you're not showing your face
it's calm
if you're showing your face it's not
come you're me if you're my girlfriend
you're me do you get it and i'm you
there should be no embarrassments if if
you drop on the floor
i'm embarrassed that's me on the floor
do you get it would you help me up
of course i would i know i should laugh
because i'll bang everyone in the face
together that's how i see a relationship
you go i'm saying
that no one should laugh she fell on the
floor like get her up now like to get
like she's drunk no she'll laugh
that's why i see stuff okay i find that
so so important
michael how do you think the date's gone
for you um the date's all right man
you're very intelligent still man
um yeah man it's a smooth one still
does my wine yep i'm not sure to be fair
the date went all right
no i was smooth man i want to link her
again still like i want to link her
again it was going well there's certain
things which were big red flags
yeah i handled the grilling world man
obviously like i'm not
i don't feel like uncomfortable i'm not
insecure like that he did handle me well
i feel he's got the kind of attitude to
deal with me the grilling was calm
i don't think he likes me actually i
don't know she likes me but she was
looking in my eyes oh by the way
she was looking in my eyes still i
really liked his honesty actually i feel
that's what
may makes me want to give him a decent
rating actually obviously i just wish
she got up man so i just
so i can get more guests yeah i'm gonna
see him again
and make him wait six months if i can't
get her
i'll find someone that looks like her
still it's not hard everyone looks the
same now
out of ten so i wanted to give him a
high score i really actually do
i think i did like a strong seven in it
seven eight
i would say i did didn't it like i think
i told her the truth in it so
like his way isn't it so i'm gonna give
him eight and
yeah eight and a half yeah eight and a
half i'm gonna stick with it
you